[Música]
estas letras revolucionarias resuenan en
el corazón de jartum en un laboratorio
ciudadano un espacio comunitario creado
en 2019 donde artistas comprometidos
pueden ensayar libremente en sus
estudios en todo el país han sido
creados 9 laboratorios ciudadanos
[Música]
el arte es un medio para enviarle un
mensaje al poder
a la sociedad a las élites políticas
el arte juega un papel importante a la
hora de mantener vivas las protestas
salgo a la calle y veo que la revolución
sigue viva
eso me motiva
cuando vuelvo de una manifestación me
siento en un buen estado de ánimo para
tocar música
[Música]
recientemente artistas de laboratorio
ciudadano de jartum fueron blanco de las
autoridades desde el golpe de estado del
ejército en octubre de 2021 los
militares siguen atacando violentamente
a los civiles revolucionarios en un año
han muerto alrededor de 100 personas en
las manifestaciones durante una
exposición de pintura que denunciaba
esta represión autoritaria nueve
artistas fueron arrestados fueron
puestos en libertad rápidamente gracias
a un grupo de abogados decidieron
redactar juntos una carta para
garantizar su libertad de expresión con
la esperanza de que algún día exista una
ley que proteja su arte
continuamos porque Nuestro objetivo es
crear un país
hemos invertido todo lo que sabemos para
contribuir a la causa
la coexistencia pacífica la gestión de
la diversidad cultural la paz en Sudán
todos los miembros de Este grupo ya han
estado en prisión algunos de ellos
perdieron a sus amigos en 2019 durante
el desmantelamiento del plantón por
parte del ejército que dejó al menos 108
muertos
hemos aceptado el hecho de que en
cualquier momento nos pueden detener o
matar
nuestras vidas no valen más que las de
aquellos que murieron antes que nosotros
Aquella tarde tres músicos asistieron a
la manifestación como casi todas las
semanas por separado para no ser
detenidos juntos
[Música]
para noni la lucha terminará cuando un
gobierno civil llegue al poder
desde el desmantelamiento del plantón
burján firma acuerdos Luego da un golpe
de estado luego nos mete en la cárcel Y
así sucesivamente es un círculo vicioso
y siempre son los primeros partidos los
que pactan con él
y somos nosotros quienes morimos en la
calle no podemos dejar de manifestarnos
porque la mitad de nuestros amigos Están
en la cárcel Yo no llevo ni cuatro o
cinco días fuera de la cárcel
va también
estos jóvenes activistas hacen todo lo
posible por defender los valores de la
Revolución protestando pero también
creando iniciativas que le den sentido a
la ciudadanía que defienden en el
laboratorio ciudadano se organiza un
taller de pintura para niños con
discapacidad aquí el arte expuesto al
servicio de los habitantes para reforzar
los vínculos de la comunidad es la
licenciada en Bellas Artes coordinadora
del espacio y también dirige talleres
intentamos explorar su potencial para
ver qué pueden hacer con los colores que
no les den miedo probar cosas nuevas
este laboratorio hace parte de las
nuevas estructuras no partidistas que
buscan estar cerca de la gente un lugar
asociativo que quiere demostrar que una
sociedad civil democrática es posible
cuando no dirige talleres slam pinta con
su antiguo profesor Aquí está pintando
la palabra Revolución junto a una
representación de la Cazadora de gas
lacrimógeno un símbolo de la revolución
la pintura transmite un mensaje de forma
muy directa
es incluso más eficaz que la música si
las palabras están escritas claramente
la imagen Es muy visible
la prueba es que la policía irrumpió en
una exposición es más expresiva que la
música o las palabras
confiscaron los cuadros porque estaban
en contra de Boom pensaban que podían
encarcelar el arte
eslam seguirá pintando mientras sea
necesario para transmitir un mensaje de
Esperanza Para apoyar a los que salen a
las calles a protestar y animar a los
que aún no lo hacen para reconstruir la
nación y para defender los derechos de
los ciudadanos